it's kind of like the guys who have the
foursome who play golf on a weekend just
kind of meeting for lunch in the middle
of the week right here we are
all gathered to talk about what's going
on in the nfl rodney when you heard the
two is gonna be the starter next time
miami plays what was your first thought
well i trust brian flores brian has um
the
opportunity to see these guys in
practice in meetings
he see their attitude he see how the
team is responding
to all the different players and i trust
him i trust that he's done a really good
job of surrounding him with quality
players
big wide receivers athletic a good
running back
good tight ends and good leadership on
the defensive side of the ball coach
yeah and i think you know the the
question was when is tua
going to be ready physically when does
he feel like hey i'm okay i'm
over this surgery and then mentally do i
have a handle on the offense
and as soon as that happens i think
you've got to put him in there and
i didn't think it was going to happen
now because fitz was playing great is
playing great
but two is the future and you've got to
you've got to get them in there i i
agree with you rodney
and you know i hope that this is bryan
flores making the decision based upon
where tua currently is what the locker
room wants and not any type
of pressure from above in the
organization all the way up to ownership
there has been some talk that it was an
ownership pick of touhou with the fifth
overall selection
and then if there is pressure from the
owner to get this guy out on the field
so they see what they have
that makes it a little more awkward but
i still endorse the idea
of finding out what this guy has let's
go let's see they may have the number
one overall pick by the time
april rolls around if the texans
continue to lose football games and they
may be looking at trevor lawrence
so let's see what tua has before we have
to make any decisions about next year
can i just ask the question in the
vision through the 2020 prism
where nothing in the future is
guaranteed sunday i watch new england
monday i watch buffalo miami looks as
close to being a division champ than
they have looked in the last seven years
so tony when i saw that i go okay i get
it but i don't get it
am i crazy well i'm with rodney
and rodney has more history with brian
flores than i do but i've talked to him
four or five times
and to me he is making decisions on
what's best for this team yes he's
looking at the future
but he realizes hey we're three and
three and we can be right in this if we
don't win the division we can be
a wild card team so if he doesn't think
chua gives them a chance to do that he's
not going to put him out there and have
him
ruin the season my guess is that he's
got confidence in him and he thinks he's
going to be fine
you know that's a great point because
last year they had every reason to keep
josh rosen on the field to see what he
could become
and brian flores decided no fitzpatrick
gives us a better chance to win
that's the guy we're going with
all right i'm out voted three to one
that's fine that's good
[Laughter]
and i'm sure rodney would remind me if
i'm wrong i i'm excited to see two of
those play and it's good that he gets
the bye week to kind of get ready
for what's coming up here in a couple of
weeks let me spin it to a team i
mentioned just before that rodney and
that's buffalo
at buffalo you felt good about when you
watch them in september and then against
two teams that we think are pretty darn
good
in tennessee and kansas city maybe we
realize the the
level of the water for where we gauge
the bills going forward
well i was i was really shocked because
a couple weeks ago i was just praising
the bill's offensive line
how well they played against the rams
and how they how well they played
against aaron donald
and it was just very surprising to see
me get see them get dominated on both
sides of the field
and i look at buffalo defensively and
i'm sitting there looking at the
television
thinking like okay leslie frazier
defensive coordinator be a little bit
more aggressive go after patrick mahomes
don't sit back in zone so
i'm sure when they're watching film
coach i'm sure leslie frazier said
there's maybe some instances where i
should have been a little bit more
aggressive but they have to get their
middle linebacker
matt milano back it seemed like they
missed him dearly
they're missing some run stoppers up
front from last year
they're missing matt milano for sure
they haven't been
the same unit and um again we're
starting to see them play against better
teams
and and to me that's the whole focus of
these next few weeks when the good teams
start playing each other
it's going to sort itself out and that's
for the reality with the bills to start
4-0 and then to get rattled back-to-back
games in prime time losing to the titans
and then losing to the chiefs
they have to be doing some soul
searching wondering where they are josh
allen mvp candidate through four weeks
now not looking as good as he did in the
early part of the season and you're
right as these good teams start to play
other good teams we find out
teams we thought were good maybe aren't
all that good after all
well i know my comrade rodney harrison
is going to get on me i was on the
cleveland bandwagon and they looked
pretty good
playing four kind of mediocre teams
played great
but they played two games against really
good teams and they got
stoned both times by baltimore first
game and then by pittsburgh
last game so how good is cleveland the
jury's still out
and coach with the buffalo bills i was
really surprised with josh allen and
just how inaccurate his
passes were it wasn't like he was taking
a bunch of shots down the field and he i
mean yeah he was throwing overthrowing
guys
but also on those shallow crossers on
those short intermediate routes
definitely a cause for concern i believe
but uh you know patrick mahomes threw it
well in that rain and wind and whatever
was going on up there so
he was off a little bit doesn't matter
if it's sunday monday night
monday at five o'clock bad weather in
buffalo in the fall is
is uh something you can count on and by
the way it's a veteran coaching move
you know when they've beat you with one
play once
figure out a way to stop it so instead
of waiting for rodney to drop the
cleveland hammer
tony took it out in coaching
and don't you miss that move young
coaches out there
going forward speaking of pittsburgh go
ahead
enrico i'm sorry i just you know i've
been with this guy this is my 12th year
with
coach dungy and he gets so excited
when teams get off to a fast start and
he's so
quick to jump on that bandwagon and
sometimes i just gotta pull him back and
humble him and say coach slow down it's
only been a month or so
don't get too excited
see look he's just accepting accepting
it yeah
accepting it and he'll move on we'll
visit back on that in november
let me ask you guys about pittsburgh who
did play cleveland
and won in a dominant fashion and
tennessee
who went to overtime and i love i love
the stuff mike frable's doing team
building
covid whatever it is and the little
wrinkle the little rule in the playbook
that he found in the rulebook that he
found
that's very much up the belichick tree
mike florio
of uh let's throw a 12th guy out there
take the penalty
and help speed the clock up so we can
get the ball back that was
all-time bella chicken and it was really
really impressive
and now they play pittsburgh we look
forward to a great game with them on
sunday
when the reporters asked mike grebel
about that monday and he said we need to
do a better job with penalties my
thought is you're doing a pretty good
job with penalties
when you're intentionally taking them to
help you win a football game you have
cracked the code on the rulebook
but you know this is old school
there should i i wish there was snow in
nashville
at any time especially in october this
just feels like one of those games
where it's 1970s and it's strength
against strength it's physical defense
for the steelers against that physical
offense and i think ryan tannehill is
going to be the key
because the steelers are going to take
away derek henry and the key to henry is
you got to get him
in those first couple steps before he
gets that head of steam going
it's going to be on tannehill to find
open guys and i tell you the thing that
stood out to me watching the steelers
browns game
that secondary is so confident in
everything they do
pre-snap post snap they know where
they're going what they're doing the
mega fits patrick pick six i guarantee
you he knew exactly what was coming
that defense has got it going like it
hasn't had in a long time
and it's gonna be a real test for the
titans
well i look at the titans and and to me
losing taylor lewand at left tackle was
a huge loss for him i mean this is a guy
that is an absolute stub one of the top
two or three left tackles in all of
football he brings
attitude he brings toughness and when
you have to go against pittsburgh and
all the different looks that they give
you
it's going to be tough and you're right
mike um ryan tanner hill is the key he's
gonna have to
try to make some plays with his legs but
not too many because
they have so much speed from sideline to
sideline yes the secondary is good but
like coach and i say every single week
there's a lot of
holes in that secondary and if they can
protect ryan tannehill they'll give him
an opportunity
with um you know aj brown and khalif
raymond and johnny smith and those guys
they've done
done a wonderful job getting
contributions from some of those lesser
named guys
and you know the best way to protect
your quarterback and slow down a pass
rush
run the football so i look for a lot of
derrick henry and
there's no guarantee pittsburgh is going
to stop him
cold i mean they may slow him down but i
look for derrick henry to be
the big factor in this game and i love
the point you made rodney off of that
with all the attention on henry
a bunch of guys are developing like
anthony fercher the tight end out of
harvard who had a touchdown in the
playoff game
against the pats he had 100 yards he had
a key block coming off the wing in
motion i mean
they're really utilizing everybody and
getting the most out of them rodney and
that's why you're starting to
really see a lot of evidence building in
the favor of tennessee could be as good
as anyone in the nfl right now
yeah they truly remind me that team
really reminds me of some of the patriot
teams that i was on um just how
unselfish this team is they're very
smart they cop
like when we used to be in meetings mike
brabel was so smart we always knew that
he was going to be a head coach because
he was always the smartest guy in a room
he was very sarcastic like most coaches
coach dungey
but he was just so but he was just so
smart and we just
we knew that we thought he was going to
be the head coach of ohio state
and it he ends up being a head coach of
the tennessee titans and he texts me
last week and i just said coach
congratulations great win
he says i love these players they play
so hard for one another i'm lucky to be
their coach so
he he loves his group of guys
mike florio i just want to bring up two
quick places in the nfl that constantly
are in the news and not because
of good news on the field the jets
and dallas it seems like each game it's
getting incrementally worse
which is shocking in dallas because mike
mccarthy was coming in
jason garrett this has been going down
one direction for many many years the
last three or four years
now you're starting to hear players
whisper the dreaded anonymous player
whispers
it's a bad scene with what's going on
especially the way they lost on monday
night to arizona
and imagine how bad it would be if they
were actually in a division that had
good teams in it
they're in first place that's what's
amazing about it now i don't know that
they can hold first place
but jerry jones said on tuesday it's
manna from heaven that they're in this
division where
the next best team is one four and one
and and so
you know they need to get the offense
better ezekiel's got this fumbling issue
in his head that he's got to figure out
how to quit thinking about it how to
hold on to the football the defense i
mean it can't get much
worse so they got to work and mike
mccarthy acknowledged this yesterday
it's on them
to figure out what their guys can do to
coach their guys up to do what they're
supposed to do and i think at some point
you got to forget what the system is and
you got to do what the guys
who you have on your team are capable of
doing and i think as it grows and
evolves
maybe the defense can get better again
it can't get much worse
and tony that's the worst thing to hear
the anonymous locker room quotes right
you know what i that was always my first
speech to to my team every year let
those guys know
we're not gonna have that i learned that
from denny green when i was an assistant
with him he said i'm telling you right
now fellas
we don't have anybody on the team name
anonymous so i better not hear from
they got the message very quickly
and guys it's also it's also up to that
that leadership in the locker room when
guys
when guys are talking to reporters and
stuff like that it's up for
those leaders demarcus lawrence you're
getting paid over 100 million dollars
you need to bring everybody together
have a players only meeting and for the
life of me i don't understand when you
have a team that has
played and performed so poorly how do
you not cut two or three guys
and maybe that gets somebody's attention
when you start seeing some starters
being released and other guys let go
rodney i know you got a tee time so i
wanted to get you going so let's uh
i don't have a t-timer oh you don't
okay famous last words i've been hey i
got to run to the grocery store on the
way to the golf course
um las vegas is playing tampa and sunday
night football
an intriguing matchup we saw the raiders
win at kansas city
and then go on the bye is there any
chance derek carr can be patrick
mahomes and tom brady in back-to-back
starts it just depends on if he if he
comes out with the mindset then i'm just
gonna let it rip and i'm gonna throw the
ball down the field
i like that i like that aggressive
mindset it feels like he has something
to prove or will he
revert back to what i used to call him
check down charlie a guy that's just
gonna
feel the pressure check the ball down
and become scared i think that's one of
the things that i'm looking for coach
well they had the raiders had a very
good
package for kansas city's blitz and they
made some big plays
they bring that back out again because
todd bowles and the bucks are not going
to let them run the football
they've got a great defensive front
seven they stop the run for everybody so
they're going to be on top
of josh jacobs derek carr is going to
have to win it they're going to pressure
him
just like they did aaron rodgers now can
you make some of those same plays up the
field
it's going to be on derek carr he's
going to have to outplay tom brady if
they're going to win this game
and i want to see which buccaneers team
shows up i mean if it's the team that we
saw at soldier field against the bears a
couple of weeks ago
i don't really believe but if it's the
team we saw against the packers i
believe and they're still
working it through they're still trying
to get better they're still coming
together as a team
we see rob gronkowski having his best
game of the season we see some of these
receivers getting healthy and we see
that defense
that defense is getting to the point
where it may be the best defense the
buccaneers have had since the days of
warren sapp and derrick brooks and john
lynch not that it's going to be
at that level but but there hasn't been
a defense in tampa like that since then
looking forward to the game there's a
bunch of things going on there bunch of
story lines you got john gruden coaching
the raiders of course coach the bucks in
the past so
you got all that stuff going on and on
top of all that you've got hall of fame
tight ends you've got jason witten there
and obviously gronk so
a ton of good story lines you know what
guys every sunday night game's been
close
fourth quarter those sunday night games
have come down to the last possession
every week this season i hope this one
does too it'd be a lot of fun
all right rodney hit him straight i mean
good luck at the algae doctor
[Laughter]
mike i'm playing golf tomorrow okay just
for your information not today
so that's why the allergy to check up
today make sure my allergies are okay
for the golf course tomorrow
guys have a great day thanks for having
me on mike florio
rodney has said goodbye for us so we'll
see you on football night seven eastern
before the raiders and the bucks on
sunday night football
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports